let's say for example we understand
that in order for a brand regardless of
what it is to reach
escape velocity you need a certain
amount of social proof and social
qualification that's a handful of
ceos like yourself that believe in it
mixed with celebrities mixed with i
don't know random [ __ ] vcs or
investors
what's stopping
you and a bunch of your buddies
from just putting together that group of
people and printing money out of thin
air making the next board ape making the
next thing because we understand it's
just a hundred people but it's not how
it actually works
it a hundred people give you a better at
bat at it i would agree with you that
the right hundred people that gonna
and ninja the gamer and drake and you
know guyos like i of cour and you like
people with platform are gonna give it
more awareness but it's like a super
bowl ad the super bowl ad is the
greatest ad in marketing why because you
get almost half the country to actually
watch it which is impossible
so it's great but if the [ __ ] 30
second video sucks [ __ ]
you [ __ ] up you could get all top
let's make a list the top 500 [ __ ]
influencers in the world that move
culture in every genre comedy rap
influencer tick-tock you know
entrepreneurship whatever it is if all
of them got behind something where the
operator where she or he was incapable
of taking that opening and driving it to
success it will go to zero and i've seen
that time and time again in startup land
and in nft land
so it doesn't matter
there's no amount of social proof that
can push a project forward if it's not
made no they can give you an opening
it's like a hot club like
excuse new york right you know this
right like a hot club we've seen it
through the years all the right people
get together it opens the first
weekend's fresh yeah you got it yeah
it's all the same [ __ ] like this is why
it's important to think
because people right now back to like
lack of accountability pointing fee like
it's it's a fun narrative like [ __ ] you
know like it's a great narrative like
those hundred people those illuminati
[ __ ] like but it's just not true yeah
yeah if it was true it would happen
every second every day all day yeah yeah
it actually works the other way
that when it's more organic of course
because the streets don't [ __ ] with it
yeah
got it yeah
by the way how you get the streets to
[ __ ] with it you've got to have a little
bit of kind of both right it's like
cooking a good meal you've got to you
got to have a little bit momma's pop you
got to be a little bit still in the dirt
you've got to actually be good actually
i'll give you a compliment right now
this is a fun segue
it's how i looked at you for a long time
you know like what's happening with you
this last year for me no different than
like gunna and other like rappers
startups facebook twitter tumblr i have
a good i've been and by the way what the
[ __ ] that i do mom and dad had sex at
the right second and gave me that dna i
have this good
intuitive feeling of like just enough
this just enough that just enough this
and for me
you know in my circles back to when i
did
the podcast with you and charlotte i
mean even like two years earlier i'm
like that guy's going to win
but it doesn't happen overnight you know
this oh yeah that was a long time ago
the reason back to your analogy why
those things if justin bieber's gotten
behind things guns really there's tons
of people the amigos like people are
getting behind [ __ ] left and right none
of it's working because it's not right
it's not right
and so
with you it couldn't you could have
gotten all 50 [ __ ] comedians that
mattered in the world and whoever was
popping on vine at the time being like
he's next yeah and it still wouldn't
have happened unless you actually had it
yeah they still try to do that with
certain people don't work it never works
i mean look at all the people that try
to do that in hip-hop sign the kids from
around the way they're gonna put them on
they're the biggest rappers at the time
right in the world
but like when snoop comes on dre's [ __ ]
it's gonna work a snoop snoop yeah but
do i have to tell you about all the
people that had features on the biggest
albums
second album of biggest rappers because
they tried to put their boys on and
those people sucked
like look i love little c's
there was only so much piggy could do it
wasn't gonna happen like that
like cease is amazing i can't wait to
run into him and give love like he sees
but he's not one of the 50 best rappers
of all time who's the little seize of
nfts
um
i have no [ __ ] idea guys that clip is
brought to you by blue chew the makers
of hard dicks and happy wives that's
right your girl deserves it even your
side chick deserves your best and the
way you're going to deliver it to her is
getting on that chew same active
ingredients that's inside cialis or
viagra but this is the chew this is the
one we rock with and this is the one
that we do spinal damage to the ones we
love with
make sure
you get your first month free by going
to bluechew.com
and use the promo code andrew you just
gotta pay five dollar shipping that's it
thank you so much for watching the clips
keep supporting the podcast we'll see
you soon
you